you cannot walk past us with this
necklace on wow and that dress and that
dress and that dress yes ma'am
i know it's crazy isn't it i keep going
oh my god like
when you saw that you were i mean
do we know how many carrots it is i
don't know but i know that like um
they're security guards
i think it's a lot
well you add security guards all right
before we get into everything talking
about tonight your birthday's coming up
what are you doing for your bro what are
you doing for your birthday birthday
um what am i doing i you know what i was
just sort of trying to get to this day
and then i think i'll deal with birthday
after the oscars
you know pam anderson just announced
that she's doing a documentary for
netflix will you be watching or do you
feel like i know everything about her
all right god no i would i want i can't
wait to watch and learn more i mean of
course we could only do our best based
on all the information we had so for her
to be able to tell her story it's so
important and so i'll be watching along
with the rest of you know the world and
eager to to to sort of you know see what
she says and hear what it's all about
i always loved the just the post the
your character in yesterday and then pam
anderson what was it like the difference
that people expected in the two
different characters they're like put on
pajamas no makeup then it's like bpam
i know it's pretty well that's what's so
cool about being an actor is you got to
do these like polar opposites i mean
they had brown frizzy hair and like you
said no makeup law and then suddenly i
was
transformed after four hours with this
incredible hair and makeup team and i'm
i you know i feel so lucky it's
it's so great it's like playing
make-believe the whole time so tell me
tonight what are you looking forward to
the most i mean you know we know some
things are happening queen bee's
performing you know is that it queen bee
i mean billy eilish like everyone's i
mean it's going to blow my mind i mean
there's also i think performed somewhere
in kanto which is incredible and you
know just seeing all these amazing you
know
it's insane the amount of movie stars in
this room is like you know before we
look
oh and i'll say also president zielinski
could pop up and speak tonight and what
would that mean and how important is
that
sorry president zielinski could also
ukraine could and how important is that
if he has a chance to speak tonight
it'll be incredible i i really hope he
does and
and that's what we need to remember
whilst this glamour's going on what's
going on in the world and i think it's
really important that we root that and
we hear you know
what's important great now i gotta get
back to the vanity question the dress
you got man
thank you
tell me about it it's versace versace um
i love it i can't believe i get to wear
it it's insane
i i actually fitted this a long time ago
before i knew today was definitely
happening so i was like fingers crossed
that i get to wear this dress i didn't
want to give it back
don't find a way to keep it because it's
amazing on you bye-bye thank you lily
[Music]